ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าป่าวอันนี้นี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
3 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้
วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 2 เดือนเดือนมิถุนายน
เมื่อปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วัน
เสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4
เดือนเนื้อเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีค.ศต.ค.
ปี
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 น 11 โมงกี่นาทีคะ 11 นาทีค่ะ 11
11 เลยนะคะเหตุนาทีนี้ก็เป็นเวลากลางวัน
ครูฟ้า
กินข้าวหรือยัง
ดูฟ้า
ใจนะเว้ยไปครูฟังเงียบไป
มากำลัง
วาดรูปอยู่ฟิว
กินข้าวแล้วค่ะครูหญิง o  o ครูฟ้ากิน
ข้าวแล้วครูฟ้ากินข้าว
กับ
แตงโมหรือเปล่าคะมีลูกก็ไม่มี
ลูก
กูมากินข้าวกับแตงโมหรอผู้หญิงผู้หญิงถาม
ไงถามครูฟ้าว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินข้าวกับแตง
โมไหม
เมื่อก็บ่เคยกินค่ะ
ค่ะอายุ 18
คู่ฟ้าอายุ 18 คู่ฟ้ากินข้าวกับแตงโม
อุ้ยเพราะว่าคุณแม่ไงคุณแม่นาคุณแม่
แม่กูฟ้าอันนี้กูฟ้าค่ะ
คุณแม่ครูฟ้ากินข้าวกับแตงโมหรอคะแม่บอก
ว่าแม่พูดเนาะคุณแม่พูดนะคะว่ากินข้าวกับ
แตงโม
โอเคนะ
แม่ก็เลยอ่ะครูฟ้าลองกิน
ลองกินค่ะไม่ขึ้นฟ้าไม่
รู้ฟ้าตอนคุณแม่บ่
ดูฟ้า
ผมคิดว่ามันแปลกหรอทำไมกินข้าวกับแตงโมคน
ไทยคนไทยเนี่ยอืมคนไทย 99 เปอร์เซ็นต์ไม่
กินข้าวกับแตงโมแน่นอนแม่พูดคือความให้
คิดแบบเฮ้ยมันแปลกอ่ะกินแหลกค่ะ
ใครใช่ไหมใครกินข้าวกับแตงโม
ไม่รู้นะแต่ว่ากูฟ้าก็โอเคกูฟ้าลองกิน
อร่อยไหมอร่อยค่ะผู้หญิง
Impossible
วิ่งก็ไม่เคยกินนะแต่ผู้หญิงเคยเห็นคนไทย
แบบศูนย์คุณย่าอย่างนี้คุณย่าใช่ไหมแก่
อายุ 80 ปีอันนี้พ่อแล้วก็แม่แล้วก็อัน
นี้หญิง
ราคานี้คุณย่ารักคุณย่าแหละกินข้าวกับ
แตงโมก็ผู้แปลกอะน่าจะไม่อร่อยเอ่อแต่
อร่อยค่ะนะเนี่ย
อร่อยอร่อยทำไมอยากผู้หญิงเอ้าก็วันนี้นะ
คะครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะมีคำถาม
ถามถามนักเรียนแล้วก็ถามครูฟ้าด้วยว่าครู
หญิงเนี่ยอย่างคู่ฟ้ากินข้าวกับแตงโม้ใช่
ไหมครูหญิงเนี่ยคิดแปลก
แต่
จ่ายค่ะวันนี้เราก็จะมาคุยกันว่าครูหญิง
ทำแบบนี้ครูฟ้าคิดว่าแปลกไหม
ครูฟ้าน่ากินข้าวกับแตงโม้ครูหญิงคิดแปลก
ไหม ahh  ahh เรียนนักเรียนก็คิดได้นะคะ
ว่าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าทำแบบนี้แปลกไหมแม่
น้าได้ค่ะครูหญิงให้ครูปลาก่อนเลยค่ะครู
ฟ้าก่อนนะคะว่ากูบ้ากินแตงโมไปแล้วไงไม่
ต้องเขียนหนึ่งด้วยหรอก็ได้ค่ะแล้วแต่ครู
ฟ้ามันก็เขียนเหมือนกับแกงอย่างแรกข้อที่
1 ของคุณฟ้าลูกฟ้าเนี่ยเลือกปลาชอบทำไม
นักษัตรบุ๊ค
เปิดโพยกันว่าจดไว้นะไม่รู้หรอไม่ต้องตด
ผู้หญิงก็จดค่ะครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
กิน
อันนี้คืออันนี้คือฟ้าตัวสีส้มนะคะ
กินอะไร
นี้ช้อนนะคะกินอ่ะ
ร้านอาหารตกใจนะว่ากินช้อนจิ้มกินอาหาร
[เพลง]
แครอท
หรือ
เอาไม่ชอบกินอะไรก็เขือเทศ
นักเรียนทั้งเปิดไฟฟ้าวาดไม่เข้าใจนะคะ
มะเขือเทศ
มีหากูป่าวเนี่ยไม่ชอบกินอ่ะ
ไม่ชอบกินแครอทไม่ชอบกินมะเขือเทศหรือกู
ฟ้าเนี่ยก็มีอาหารที่ไม่ชอบกินใช่ไหมคะ
แค่ตลอดมะเขือเทศเนี่ยไม่ชอบกินกลิ่นไง
แต่ครูฟ้ากินค่ะผู้หญิง
ถ้าเกิดมีแครอทมีมะเขือเทศวางอยู่แต่กู
ฟังนะ
แม่งก็
แปลกแปลกไว้
ครูหญิงคิดว่าแปลกค่ะครูผู้หญิงไม่ชอบกิน
ไม่ชอบกินแครอทมีแครอทเพลงออกไม่กินไม่
กินแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินได้กินได้ค่ะหรือถ้า
มี cannot วางอยู่ใช่ไหมกูมาไม่ชอบกิน
แครอทแต่กูฟ้าก็แครอทแล้วค่ะกินกิน
นักเรียนนักเรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้าแปลกไหมครู
หญิงคิดว่าแปลกค่ะแม่
ค่ะแปลกนะคะใช่ค่ะนักเรียนก็จะมีเมนูหลาย
ๆเมนูให้ไหมเมนูพาไม่ชอบแล้วก็มีนะคะแต่
ถ้าเกิดมีเมนูนั้นวางอยู่ครูบาก็กินใช่
แปลกค่ะอ่ะ
อันนี้คือแปลกหรอผู้หญิงแปลก
มึงเหงาของผู้หญิงบ้างค่ะผู้หญิงกิน
เหมือนกันนักเรียนจะคิดว่าคนส่วนใหญ่เรา
จะเห็นเรื่องกินเนาะนี่
อะไรคะครูฟ้าไอศครีมโคน
อะไรเนี่ย
S  sasa
อิซซ่าอ่อนงอครูหญิงน่ะเวลากินพิซซ่าครุย
เนี่ยใช้ช้อน
แล้วก็ซ่อม
กินพิซซ่า
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าแปลกไหมใช้ช้อนแล้วก็ซ่อมกิน
พิซซ่าผู้หญิงไม่ก็มีหรออย่างน้อยถ้าเป็น
นี่มันก็ยังเอาก็มีด้วยก็ได้อ้ะมีด้วย
ก็คือปกตินักเรียนเนี่ยใช้มือใช่ไหมใช้
มือกินพิซซ่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ใช้มือกิน
พิซซ่าใช้ช้อนส้อมหรือว่ามีดกินพิซซ่าครู
ฟ้าเลยครูฟ้าคิดว่าแปลกไหม
แปลกค่ะ
หนูมันแปลกถ้าใช้ช้อนใช้ส้อมแปลกค่ะผู้
หญิง
ลิมิตด้วย
แล้วก็ใช้ช้อนส้อมทำไมล่ะต้องมันครั้งไม่
มีมี่ก็ใช้ช้อนหันได้นะแล้วทำไมคุณหญิง
ไม่ใช้มือ
แล้วก็ยิงแล้วก็แกะใช่ไหมเมื่อใส่อ่ะไม่
เอามึงเนอะ
นักเรียนคิดว่าแปลกไหมใช้ช้อนใช้ส้อมเอา
มีดกินพิซซ่านะคะครูฟ้าค่ะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
มีขนมเห็นไหม
เลนักเรียนเลค่ะ
เวลาเราเรียนกินขนมรอเรียกขนมนะคะเวลาเรา
อีกทีขนมน้องเองก็ใช้มือใช่ไหมหยิบกิน
หยิบกิน
[เพลง]
พอใช้ช้อนกับส้อมเหรอ
ครูขวัญใช้อะไรผิดผม
กู้ไฟล์ใช้ตะเกียบผู้หญิง
ตรงเพราะวันนี้ก็ไม่แปลกเท่าไหร่นะ
คุยก็เคยเห็นนะมันมี 1 อันหรอแต่ว่าก็ไม่
แหกน้ำรู้ก็แปลกนิดหน่อยอ่ะ
ขอแรงแรงอีกหน่อยเพราะว่าครูหญิงอ่ะใช้ 1
ใช้ช้อน
ฟ้าใช้ส้อมใช่ไหมผู้หญิงอ่ะใช้ช้อนนะคะ
เออก็แปลกนะแบบปกติทุกคนก็ใช้มืออีกรู้
สึกแปลกแต่ไม่มากอาใช้ตะเกียบใช่ไหมมัน
ไม่โอเคต้องล้างมือด้วยซุปโต๊ะค่ะไม่ต้อง
ล้างมือมีโอเคนักเรียนคิดว่าแปลกไหมครู
ฟ้าใช้ตะเกียบกินขนมมาหาไม่ได้ใช้กินข้าว
นะกินขนมเท่านั้นขนมถูกต้องค่ะอ่ะครูหญิง
ครูหญิงจะพูดถึงยายานะคะยาหย่าหย่าไอเวลา
ที่กินยาสมัยเราก็จะมีแก้วแล้วก็ได้แก้ว
ก็จะมีน้ำอ่าแล้วก็ในส่วนเป็นยายะยานะ
นิยานะผมกติเนี่ยครูฟ้าหรือทุกคนแหละและ
ก็จะกินยาเอายาใส่ปากแล้วก็ 2 ดื่มน้ำ
ใช่ไหมคะแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยเวลาที่ครูหญิง
กินยากูหญิงเนี่ยหนึ่งดื่มน้ำ 2
เอายาใส่แล้วก็กลืนคือผู้หญิงเนี่ยกินน้ำ
ก่อนกินยาครูฟ้าคิดว่าแปลกไหม
น้ำก่อนกินยาคูลท์ก็คิดว่าไม่แปลกทำไมอ่ะ
เพราะตอนเด็กๆฟ้าก็กินแบบนี้นะคะวันนี้
ล่ะวันนี้ไม่กินแล้วค่ะไม่กินยาอ้าว
ตอนนี้ไม่กินค่ะวันนี้ก็เอายาก่อนแล้วก็
ค่อยดื่มน้ำแต่ว่าเอายายใส่ในน้ำ
คลินิกแตก
คะอันนี้แปลกนะครับแปลกนั่นแหละขอ
โทษผู้หญิงเอายาใส่น้ำแล้วก็ดื่มไปเลยมัน
ก็คงสิ
โอเคนะผู้หญิงไม่ชอบไม่ได้ชอบเพราะมัน
ยามันขมแต่ไม่ชอบยาแล้วก็นี้ลิ้นของเรา
ใช่ไหมอะนี้ปากอ้ะปากแล้วก็มีลิ้นไม่ชอบ
ยาโดนลิ้นเสือเอ้ยเออก็เลยดื่มน้ำก่อนไง
ยังเออต่อไปผู้หญิงเอายาใส่ในน้ำดื่มที
เดียวหญิงอันเนี้ยแปล
ไปทำแบบนี้นักเรียนคิดว่าแปลกไหมคอมเมนท์
ได้นะคะมีนายดูฟ้าค่ะข้อต่อไปของครูฝา
เรื่องต่อไป
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี
ขาเท้าเอาผู้หญิงไม่ได้แปลก
ถ้าคุณ
มีดาวหนา
แล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็จะมีดีอะไร
อันเนี้ย
อะไรคะรองเท้าหรอใช่ค่ะรองเท้า
ผู้หญิงก็มีรองเท้านี่แปลก
ผู้หญิงยังไม่จบค่ะสุดเท้าคู่ฟ้าเนี่ย
40  cm เป็นผู้หญิงเหรอ 10 เส้นเลยหรอ
เอ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ย 24  cm
เขาปลูกปลาเนี่ยมีไม้บรรทัดวัด 10 เส้น
ไปรองเท้าแปลก
เท้าหุ้มฝาเนี่ยจะเอา 40 เซนติเมตรแหวก
ขาย
ไม่ใช่เหรอนักเรียนไว้เขียนผิดนะไม่ใช่
40%
ใส่ไรฮ้าวไป
สุภาเด้อใส่รองเท้าไซส์ 40 ได้มานิแต่รอง
เท้าหูฟ้าเนี่ย 38
คือตอนแรกในผู้หญิงคิดว่ากรูฟ้าเนี่ยรอง
เท้าไซส์ 40 แล้วครูฟ้าใส่รองเท้า size
41 คือ
4  11 อันเนี่ยผู้หญิงคิดไม่แปลกก็ครู
หญิงเนี่ยเหมือนกัน
ใส่รองเท้าใหญ่กว่าเท้าตัวเองผู้หญิงจิต
ไม่แปลกนะคะแต่ใส่รองเท้า
ดีกว่าเท้าตัวเองแปลกมากค่ะแล้วคือมัน
เจ็บมากเลยนักเรียนแบบนิ้วภูฟ้านิ้วก็ฟ้า
ก็อยู่ดีๆใช่อยู่กับเจ็บน่ะ
คุณพ่อก็บอกว่าซื้อรองเท้าใหม่
ใช่มั้ยคุณพ่อบอกให้ไปซื้อรองเท้า
ไซส์ 40 ผู้หญิงมีคำถามค่ะทำไมครูฟ้าต้อง
ใส่รองเท้าไซส์เล็กกว่าเท้าอ่ะ
ฟ้าซื้อมาแล้วไงไม่อยากซื้อใหม่
ก็ทำไมตอนซื้อไม่ดูไซส์ 40 เหรอคะมันหมด
ค่ะ
คุยรู้สึกว่าไม่ใช่แล้วสาวคิดว่าคุณน่ะ
แปลก
ต้องสาวทั้งหมดเนี่ยคุณคุณแปลกนักเรียน
เพราะว่าตอนที่ครูฟ้าไปดูอ่ะเอ่อมันจะ
เป็นร้านรองเท้าใช่ไหมเราก็จะมีถ้าจะมา
หน้าแดงเลยไม่เอาก็จะมีชั้นอย่างนี้ให้
ไหมคะค่ะฉันมันก็จะมีรองเท้า
รองเท้ารองเท้ารองเท้ารองเท้ารองเท้ามาก็
หาไซส์ 40
size  40  size  40  size  40 ไม่มี
มันมี 38
ครูฟ้าใสไม่ได้แต่ตัวฟ้าซื้อมาก็ซื้อมา
เอาแปลกแรกตั้งถึงคิดแล้วเราจะมา
วันที่เธอไม่เป็นไร 38 โอเคนะคะแล้วก็
เจ็บโอ้ยเวลาใส่รองเท้าแล้วเดินนี่มันก็
เจ็บโอ้ยเจ็บแปลกข่าวแปลก
ใช้เอาผู้หญิงกูมาแล้วยังใส่รองเท้าไซส์
38 อยู่นะคะที่มี
แล้วนักเรียนคิดว่าถ้าครูขยันผู้หญิงใช่
ไหมผู้หญิงเนี่ยใส่รองเท้าจะเอาไซส์ 37
ผู้หญิงจำไม่ได้หรอกค่ะแต่ผู้หญิงรู้สึก
ว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยเท้าผู้หญิงน่ะ
ยาว
23  cm
พูดอะเอาตัวเองออกไปได้ไหม
แต่ครูผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบใส่รองเท้า
ยาว
cm
ใหญ่กว่าเท้าตัวเองคือผู้หญิงคิดไม่แปลก
นักเรียนคิดว่าแปลกไหมอันนี้ไม่ใช่คำถาม
นะคะของผู้หญิงได้แต่กูคิดว่าโอเคเพราะ
ว่าตอนเด็กๆฟ้าก็ใส่รองเท้าไซส์ใหญ่กว่า
ขาวกว่าฟ้าแต่ไซส์เล็กกว่าเท้าเนี่ยแปลก
แน่นอนค่ะค่ะครูหญิงอ้าของผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
มีแต่เรื่องกินน่ะๆๆ
แต่ตอนนี้แล้วกันครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนที่
ชอบดูหนังเหมือนเดิม
ชอบฟังเพลงเหมือนเดิมก็กินเหมือนเดิมคือ
ผู้หญิงชอบอะไรที่มันเหมือนเดิมตัวหน้า
ผู้หญิงเปิด YouTube ใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนมี
YouTube เนี้ยเราก็เป็นเพลงเป็น Playlist
Playlist เพลงเป็นเพลงนักเหมือนเดิมผู้
หญิงเนี่ยฟัง Playlist เนี้ย 1 เดือนทุก
วันทุกวันทุกวันพอมันเล่นแล้วก็จบแต่คุณ
ก็กลับมาสตาร์ทใหม่แล้วมันก็เล่นจบจริงก็
สตาร์ทใหม่เล่นจบทีก็สตาร์ทใหม่เล่นจบนี่
ก็สตาร์ทใหม่
หรือว่าดูหนังสมัยดูหนังอ่ะสมมุติ
ไอรอนแมนผู้หญิงชอบมากๆดูขอดู
ทุกวันไม่ใช่ทุกวันน้อง 1 อาทิตย์
1 ครั้งเนี้ยนักเรียนและครูฟ้าคิดว่า
แปลกไหม
แปลก
หรอก็ทำนะห้าเปอร์เซ็นไอ้ที่เข้าไปแต่ง
นี้เราก็ทำ
พ่อค้าก็ทำไง
แปลกนิดหน่อยใต้แต่นักเรียนล่ะนั้นเองคิด
ว่าแปลงคบผู้หญิงหรือฟ้าเหมือนกันนะคะ
อย่าเว้นดูหนังดูหนังเนี่ยภูฟ้าไม่ไม่ดู
ซ้ำๆเท่าไหร่ไม่เท่าไหร่ไม่แต่ฟังเพลงกิน
อาหารเนี่ยเราจะทำซ้ำๆซ้ำๆ
ผู้ชายชอบเพลงแบบรู
ใช่เหมือนกันอย่างนี้ก็ชอบลูกผิดก็เปิดวน
เหมือนเดิมเหมือนเดินนักเรียนผู้หญิง
เนี่ยสมมติว่าผู้หญิงชอบเมื่อก่อนคุยชอบ
เพลง 1 เพลงผู้หญิงก็ฟังเพลงเดียวนะ 1
เนื้อเพลง 1 ชั่วโมง
1 เพลง 1 ชั่วโมงเปิดก๊อกรบยกกดใหม่คุย
ชอบแบบนี้แล้วเรียนคิดว่าเราสองคนแปลกไหม
นี้ก็คอมเม้นต์ได้นะนักเรียนแต่วันนี้หมด
เวลาแล้วนะผู้หญิงใส่ค่ะเดี๋ยวเราเจอกัน
ใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
แป๊บนึงนะคะปิดไม่ได้อ่ะ